you
it's always difficult to look forward
and to imagine what the next most
important thing is but let me tell you
I'm happy that we've made or overcome
let's say the first digital revolution
and we can get past problems of
visualization and even the problems of
of building so we can assume that to
some degree I'd also like to think that
we can get around the hurdle of
sustainability with some ease the notion
that problems of sustainability can be
assumed in the same way that railing
heights and other codes may be assumed
in architecture these are these don't
have intellectual stakes they are merely
part of the technical infrastructure
that we have to deal with the question i
guess that looms for me right now is
with the accessibility to design to the
larger masses with our ability to
communicate and see works across the
continents across the age groups with
our ability to publish ourselves from a
blog to a site to a book to a magazine
how is it that questions of criticism
gauge in the future education of the
architect what is a critical inquiry and
secondly to what degree are we able to
overcome our fascination with monocular
projects projects that are only invested
in sustainability or projects that are
only invested in geometry how is it that
we can imagine works of architecture
that deal with the problem of
integration or synthesis without the
kind of overarching philosophies that
we've inherited from the fosters and the
pianos how do we deal with the
exceptionality of the synthetic moment
in inventive ways and that
that I think will separate the great
architects from the masses